a theater I believe that any future
government will see this project as a
good business and will support it just
as the current Chancellor and the
current foreign minister do I have no
worries on that score have you quickly
cunning sir
don't you see the danger that because of
this power vacuum in Berlin German
interests in Brussels are of course that
could be the case that's why I'm one of
those who say let's get a move on let's
act as soon as possible new Krishna
what's your advice to your party and
your coalition or loose corporations you
can drop the dramatics and get on with a
grand coalition what else do you think
that in future governments in Germany
will always take so long to fall it's
difficult this is the first time that
we've got a Six Party Parliament two of
those parties are not seen as potential
coalition partners in fact they aren't
capable of being in a coalition the left
on the one hand and the AFD on the other
that's why it will become more difficult
so I'm telling my party very frankly
there's no way around it you have to
take on this responsibility you have to
convince the party members that this is
necessary and do it quickly Europe needs
it Europe needs a stable France which
they've got in the form of macron and
Europe needs a stable Germany with this
in mind I believe the sensible thing to
do is to form a government quickly and
as things stand the only option is a
grand coalition that's what we should do
no one profits from new elections and no
one profits from playing around with
other ideas like case-by-case
cooperation or whatever that won't get
us anywhere both want repeal align it so
we're in Turku chord IV medicine and it
does fit also mix which cost should the
new government take on Russia what do
you advise their cooperation rather than
confrontation
that's the sensible way to go we need
the equivalent of a new policy of
Daytona it's about time it's high time
I'm in favor of the step-by-step removal
of sanctions dependent on how things go
and Don bass
we should not always be talking about an
escalation or when there are prisoner
exchanges when the heavy weapons are
withdrawn verified and supervised by the
appropriate people then we should go
ahead and say okay we see this goodwill
and we want to reward this by
dismantling sanctions on step by step
and by the way has the economic research
institutes tell us of the sanctions do
most damage to Germany fiscal show Tom
Schaad near for an England view of ISM